anyways so yeah they brought you in and
with a bunch of people they weren't
arresting you no they weren't arrested
they do
they they were trying to figure out who
i was who i knew
um i'm trying to get more people taken
yeah i had to give up all my passwords
to all my emails all my icq chats all of
the forums
you know so i'm sure that they're like
if you log on we'll know if we see you
on any of the [ __ ] forums we'll know
you know what i mean blah blah blah
we'll come and arrest you
so i was like you know it is what it is
and they know they didn't take me to
jail it was weird and you know and
they just after that after i went there
and i met with all those people and they
were asking me all these questions i got
interrogated you know do you know this
person
and they show me this they're like do
you know this they show me screen names
do you know this person you deal with
this person you know do you speak
russian do you code
all this [ __ ] you know and um
do you code yeah they want to know if i
was like you know
they wanted to know what the spectrum
what my what my spectrum of knowledge i
think was
you know to try and to see where they
could implement me you know because
there was this whole what was the
name of the operation remind me matt
well uh
open market open market yeah there was
operation open market going on at this
time
what's that that's the isn't that matt
can explain it a little bit better than
i can because matt you actually
researched it that i didn't really do
because you know basically he was
basically there was a
carter.su like
carter.su was the the one that
the the main forum that he was using
and they got and so what happened was
afterwards keep in mind
after he left i'm still getting
documents in
so things he's telling me happen when
you say after he left
after after john left prison okay i had
written a synopsis
and i had like 60 pages of notes right
60 70 pages of just
notes so i started getting stuff in i
got an
the indictment the carter.su indictment
i'm pretty sure it's open market yeah
it's it's open market dark market was
the other one open market
so carter.su was being run
out of russia
um and that was the forum and the secret
service
had an investigation into it and was
called uh um operation dark market no
open market
operation open market where they
indicted like i don't know what they
150 or 50 people something like 50 or
100 people whatever
and a whole bunch of john does and that
sort of thing i'm sorry i'm sorry
after he leaves south carolina they let
him go he he's interviewed
like there's a lot of little things like
i didn't know like he just said they
took pictures of him in front of ups
store like i didn't even know that
like i like i was like when he said that
it was like a booking yeah i was
but in front of the ups store like i
didn't know that like i'm thinking
that's kind of you know they turn you
know wit in you know i'm saying yeah
right there like i didn't know that um
i remember the thing where the blow
thing because i mentioned that in the
book the blow thing where you
you said that it flashed through your
head anyway so after he leaves there for
south carolina
he goes and gets some cash and he gets
money out of the bank
right how much money did you have in the
bank at this point
about 200 grand okay my boa
so he um no i think he's talking about
the money that was in
like u.s plastic oh like in the [ __ ]
couple million what was u.s u.s plastico
was what
the u.s plastico account oh yeah yeah at
this point yeah
so u.s plastico right remember that's
the cor that's the
that [ __ ] a my eye is i think i just
rubbed something in my eye okay sorry
he laughs um uh
what are we talking about now we're
talking about in south carolina
after the secret service lets you go and
you go to miami yeah and a little over
two and a half million dollars or
something like that bank at this time
yeah yeah yeah but he goes and gets a
couple hundred thousand out of the bank
and then he gets a like a hundred
thousand or so in cash he had weren't
you
you were cool with keeping two and a
half million dollars in the bank at this
point like
yes yeah the service on your ass well
the account wasn't in my name
obviously yeah nothing okay i set the
account up so there's you didn't feel
like there was any
risk in keeping there was no risk there
was no risk at all because it was a
corporate account
okay and you know what i had a corporate
account that was in a business's name
that you were not affiliated exactly
yeah that is set up under a guy
yeah exactly okay yeah so he grabs 101.
so you grab some of the money make a
fake [ __ ] person's got a bank account
with two and a half million in it
so he grabs some of the money goes back
to miami
obviously there's a warrant out first
well well i guess they
this time there was no there wasn't them
but they indict you they wait yeah yeah
yeah they waited like a couple years
right
like three years yeah i put a warrant
out for my arrest right i thought i had
[ __ ]
years after that i thought i had gotten
away with everything
because yeah remember he goes he goes he
still uses he uses his real id to go in
and buy a gun because listen at this
point i thought i was going hey i
thought i was going to prison
i'm convinced that i'm going to prison
right but after so long
you know what a half years yeah how old
are you at this point uh
late 20s oh maybe mid-20s 25 26 27 yeah
i went to prison when i was 27 so
yeah yeah so he goes then he goes to
miami 24 years old with two and a half
million bucks in the bank from credit
card fraud listen
that's pretty wild yeah how many [ __ ]
cadillacs have you owned oh
all of them i mean you know
like i did yeah yeah now it's my first
one you worked at a chevy uh
uh no i worked for gm i worked for
general motors when i was like 19.
yeah and then you know i watched all the
dope boys growing up driving cadillacs
and [ __ ] you know what i mean and then i
i finally got my sts
uh no but not so much the dunks they
were like the older you know the 60s 67
77 like the 70s from the 70s i'm more
like yeah
i'm more like 80s okay 80s muscle cars
you know like the dope boys the
cutlasses the regals the monte carlos
you know and i mean and then like uh
i started getting into like the caddies
like sts the cts
i had them all i had a deville had the
dhs
had two dhs's i had three cts's i had
four sts's i had a red one a white one a
black one
wow yeah gave a gave a [ __ ] cadillac
away to some stripper
yeah yeah why'd you give it to her
suck good dick really yeah that's worth
it yeah it's worth a cadillac i don't
know about
that um but anyway so yeah so he goes
back to miami and goofs off for like a
year
and that's when you met what i forget
what was the rich kids what was the rich
kid's name
oh you're not my wife you're talking
about the rich kid giovanni giovanni
yeah giovanni
yeah who was giovanni euro trash she was
[ __ ] just this kid i met in miami
beach this [ __ ] trust fund kid
living off his dad's money and uh you
know just euro trash
strip club [ __ ] cocaine partying you
know what i mean just
that type of dude but he was plugged in
everywhere he knew everybody
really every [ __ ] buddy dude he knew
everybody like he had he had a badass
[ __ ] uh
condo at the top floor of this [ __ ]
this building on brickell in downtown
miami
and amazing we used to party like i've
never been to brooklyn i remember going
to his i got out of prison oh really
yeah i remember going to his place and
partying dude with like brook hogan's
like financial district
and [ __ ] amazing doing a lot of
[ __ ] people would be there just
[ __ ] hanging out and walking up like
what the [ __ ] is going on here dude you
know what i mean
it's just wild [ __ ] the chick from um
that one chick from uh uh orange is the
new black
name american pie
she was in orange is the new black as
well oh is she yeah what's her name
natasha leone or whatever is that her
name
i don't know no no she's she's a
comedian actually she's actually a
really funny comedian no it's something
like that who is this kid giovanni
what's up
giovanni like i said he's just a [ __ ]
euro trash you know but he was he was
he what was his connection oh nothing no
i was just saying dude
no no nothing but yeah that's just like
part of the wild just the wild [ __ ] i
went because
he basically went for like a year
there's so many characters like that guy
in miami i feel like
he went for like a year or so and didn't
do anything like didn't didn't
do anything but just basically hang out
with giovanni and party
and party and blow money but then the
money ran a lot of money
yeah and then he started carting again
that's when the second indictment that's
when
that's why i was saying i got another
indictment in remember
okay do you think if you wouldn't have
started karting again you would have
never gone to prison
well there still would have been yeah i
mean i had a warrant you know at that
time
so i was going to prison it was
inevitable you know what i mean i had a
mandatory minimum
by the way a mandatory minimum of 24
months with the aggravated identities
after i got everything you know reduced
down i mean right they won that was like
100
10 months 10 years like what 150 months
120
120
months that's what i was looking at
initially it was 120 months
yeah at 25 i was 26
yeah so i would i would be almost 40 by
time i got up
so he started carting again went back on
the forum
started carting all i knew that's what i
did because you basically ran out money
you weren't working you were
spending all the millions that you had
yeah i was running through it pretty
fast
you